hello everyone so it's a real pleasure
to be here and especially on this last
day so amazed that by the number of
people that are still here after all
this time and I'm going to talk about
federated learning and this between
machine learning so just before starting
this presentation what I would like to
know is who here before coming to PI
data knew about new bank ok who here
after like spending three days a year
like no bit more about giving okay
that's fine and my last question is I
guess you know like on the description
it was really like this between machine
learning but I guess here like the more
central point is going to be like
federated learning and I guess it's kind
of like a new field that appear like two
three years ago and I would like to also
like who here know about fidelity
learning interesting so at least you
will you know learn about something new
today and when you will leave this room
you will be able like to maybe you know
talk with your friend with your
colleague about this new field inside
like machine learning so first I would
like to just you know introduce myself
sherry I'm working at the bank for since
like 2016 so more than three years and a
half
I'd like to master degree from France
and from the US where I did computer
engineering and computer science and
then after that I decided to continue
with PhD in Germany where worked on
recommendation system and I always kind
of put like factorization machine
because sometime there is just like one
person in the room that heard about this
algorithm and maybe you like work on
that especially if you do like
recommendation system so I don't like if
you are this person like this come and
say hi I would love to talk with you and
otherwise just before we start the
presentation it's also like this you
know shall we tell you like a bit more
about new things so Ewbank is the
leading financial technology company in
Latin America so if you don't count even
India in China just by the sheer number
were like the biggest FinTech company in
the world and we launched like in 2014
like a new fee no credit card that you
can just like manage in the app we have
more than 13 million customer we are
like this year expanding in Mexico and
Argentina so a bit like why we are here
and we're like giving some presentation
because we like to you know be a bit
more known that's like what I saw at the
beginning of the presentation and we
were elected like the most innovative
company in Latin America and I think on
this point let's also like to go back to
be done like the presentation we always
tried like to do innovative stuff so we
try to you know apply stead of the
outlet or do we try to apply algorithm
that we think are like really
interesting and I can help or it's like
bottom line or the way we are either
like treating your customer or doing
business and for that a bit of you know
what is like related to that so in a way
fidelity learning is not something that
we are using today at Eubank but this is
like kind of like a new method that's
were like looking at because as you can
expect today you know a big company like
a bank or if we think about you know
what it's like Instagram Spotify
MercadoLibre we are like a lot of data
and most of this data is not generated
on the other side but generated on like
the side of the customer so what we like
to do is to really focus on like
multiple points so usually when we talk
about like this centralized data we talk
about trying to do all like most of the
computation on the side of the customer
and usually when we talk about you know
on device inference for example we talk
about you know improving the latency
improving like the privacy battery life
of people and you know like the fact
that this can work offline so in some
way for this presentation I will most
like focus on the privacy advantages I'm
mostly like focusing on that because
like the field is really big and in 30
minutes going to be really hard for me
to just go through everything and being
able to be like clear enough so at the
end you don't you know like you had it
doesn't explode at the end so I would
like care about like the privacy
advantages here so just to go back a bit
the feel of like federated learning
cannot like started with Google in 2015
where like the core idea was solve
machine learning problem locally on user
devices and what is going to happen is
everything that is happening in user
devices is going to be like aggregated
and sent to like the server inside the
company but you will kind of like never
see the data from the customer only some
update and that will explain later
so yeah mostly that's so in some way if
you look at like distributive
optimization for like machine learning
again what's going to happen is the data
that we enact optimizes is like
distributed unevenly so in some way we
have you know unbalanced data in a sense
that like some users are going to be
like more active than some other users
so we some users are going to generate
way more data than some other user over
like a large number of nodes so again
here we're talking about you know like
kind of like massively distributing in
the sense that we're going to use the
cell phone directly like the smart phone
of every user like to do some
computation like this competition is not
going to be like would it be but it's
still going to delete some computation
and usually what we're like thinking is
during this process the training process
is going to be much bigger than like the
average number of people that we have in
or let's say like contexts in like the
gravit of like all the users of this we
have and yeah like we refer to that too
as like federated optimization where
again we have you know like a lot of non
iid data and what I'm saying like non-id
data is like since the data that were
receiving is usually like from just like
one client or a gluteal client but like
if we just look at like one particular
user like this data set is not going to
be like representative of like the
general distribution that we have one we
it's like a good gauge everything and
the last point that I didn't talk about
is the limited communication so on this
point again what we're thinking is you
know like when we're thinking about it
select Latin America if you are you know
either in Brazil in Argentina
most likely there is like
of the country where you have like no
network so it means that if you are like
relying your internet like 100 percent
of the time well it's you know what are
you bad for you
so you want to you know be able like to
build something there's going to be
these going to work without internet or
at least Intel connection that easy like
sporadic so once in a while and again
you're like doesn't necessary connection
to do that so I'll go next to kind of
like a an example so if you know that is
something that is called like the glide
typing from the Google like keyboard and
in fact what is like in proceed is not
so much like the like typing and then if
it's like amazing technology but
something that you might have seen at
some point is just like this piece of
information so every time you like
taking your word you see that you know
like this like what it was like the blue
arrow there is three recommendation of
word that we might you know after like
the the sequence of characters were
typing so in this example like I try
like this morning of you know just
typing panada is good and then stop
typing and Google was just recommending
me like ID time was things and the way
it works is by using your recurrent
neural Nets model that is like
distributed and on device and that is
using like fidelity learning to do that
so kind of like to go and you like the
example that we've seen until now what
we're trying to do is like to be able to
develop state of the art machine
learning so in the case of you know the
Google keyboard it was like a recurrent
internet so we're not talking about you
like very small model or really
simplistic model we're talking already
you know kind of like deep learning
model and what we're trying to do here
is we're trying again to not you know
every time send the data back to Google
because in some way you know when you're
doing a communication with people like a
lot of company really like value privacy
and if you know like I'm not sure if
everyone like coding care or maybe not
but I
you know Google or Facebook to know you
like what I'm talking about my friend
with my girlfriend or like the people I
work with and that's something that's
like personal and I really value like
the fact that you know like everything
is just like staying on my phone and
we're not like just sending you like
bunch of texts to some big company that
is doing like some machine learning on
top of that and again just to like
reinforce like this idea is like data is
usually born not unlike the company
server but unlike the customer device
and you know we can talk about usually
like the private data so maybe you know
like say you're doing some registration
for some company today you have to maybe
like generate 12 like the email we like
the company will need it maybe to send
you some communication but let's see if
we talk about the edge of someone the
race of someone some let's say like more
like private information for from a
customer this is like the kind of data
that's a lot of company our skin and in
the case of new bank for example we have
like a really huge team of people in
information security is making sure that
you like this data is like predicted
that you know like if I cure I strain
like to get these data is like really
hard for them or almost impossible and
maybe here what we want to do is is like
maybe a way to not you know receive this
data but still be able like to do
machine learning and I think if we were
able like to do that well you know it
would like remove a lot of you know
anxiety that we might have in like
getting all these data and storing it
and making sure that this data is not
available for it's like bad people so
what do we need to do that
in a sense it's really simple there's
kind of like a three steps process but
as you can imagine you know usually like
the devil is like in the details and
most of the time you know I just one of
those point is Luther spoke paper
written by you know a lot of different
researcher so let's just try by the
first like the NL optimizer and this one
is kind of like the easiest one as you
can imagine it's like working distance
and factors like week writing distant
because as you can imagine you know if
you have to do like pure gradient
descent on like on the phone usually
great in this sense is you know asking
us to go through all the different data
that we are and then like
like the gradient at the end and it's
like too expensive in a case because
again what we want to do is just you
know extend like updates as soon as we
can add them or you know as like some
kind of like batches so in this way what
we'll use is well to get it going
distance and here usually you know it's
like it works way better when we just
have like a run of computation it's
usually like pretty low like to compute
so there was like a nice paper that was
like release is not so long ago call
like distributed machine running on
mobile devices and they did a kind of
like a survey of you know ik multiple
technique for like machine learning
optimizer and here you can see like
SGD you can see like SVR G which is like
stochastic variance ridges gradient atom
of well HDD for a consequence and
usually what is like the cost of using
like those different let's say
optimization method to to do some
optimization in some way the second part
is usually like the distributed
optimizer so in some way if you kind of
like think about it
it's a bit of doing like MapReduce so we
are in like a really huge program that
we want to tackle but what we have is a
lot of like small worker which is here
in like the smartphone doing the work
for you so what you're trying to do is
you know it's like really hard to train
like a full model on a single mobile
device and you want to like divide this
task in like you know all the different
nodes that you are inside like you the
graph of high quality customer and
what's going to happen is like each of
those workers just going to deal with
like a small specific problem so in this
case just doing your like some
optimization using virgin reading
descent or like some of the data that
you might have and then after that you
know like we have some kind of like
manager that is just going like to get
everything together and like process it
so again if we think about it on mobile
on mobile devices the availability of
like the network is something that is
like sensitive and if we think you know
like in terms of like distributed
programming the way that's like Amazon
is doing or Google is doing but just
having like those really like gigantic
server doing
of computation I think here like on the
other case is it's like different you
know like we don't have maybe like power
every time you know if you phone is like
dropping down you need to make sure they
start like you know bringing like the
whole network down so this is I think
that you have like to get in mind you
need also like to reduce like the
communication because again if you think
that like the network is an issue you
might also think that in some part of
the country like people don't have you
know like a 10 gigabyte like provider
that is able like to stream Netflix for
example and you like to be very careful
so like the few information that you're
going to send is going to be like very
important so you like to be careful in
your like this amount of information
that you have to say so we are like this
reduce of you know communication around
but also there is something that you
collect communication compression and
maybe for some of you you might have
heard of this term because there is like
two way of doing it so there is one
which we call that structure updates so
in like quickly it's just like applying
restriction to update during that dog
training process and usually here is
kind of you know you have some result
and you want to like reduce it by using
for example like low range compression
or like some random mask and otherwise
you are like sketch updates so usually
like the compression here is done after
you do the training and before the
communication so in this case you are
like subsampling or maybe here people
know about like cancellation so instead
of you know sending let's like float
number you're just going to say oh like
all the different weight of my model are
going to be represented we've just let's
like eight beats so you can like way
reduce the amount of data that you're
sending instead of you know sending 64
32 bits of information every time and
then the last point that is for me like
the most important because like the one
from before like the first point you
know as I said is mostly like
optimization we all know you know
reading distance the second point is
something that was also like done before
in a way of you know like MapReduce
being able like to distribute
like the computation to multiple nodes
and the last point is that aggregation
so as I said the beginning
once the training is finished inside the
device of someone we need like this
information to go back to like the
server and to be able like to use this
information to also update all the
different notes inside like the graph of
all the customer that we have so if you
just apply updates to the global model
of one by one is going to get you know
really complicated and usually one of
the big issue that you will face is like
the model concerns like very quickly the
fact that you know again we are like an
imbalance in terms of user like some
user are going to generate a lot of data
when some other users are going to
generate a lot of data so you might have
like some issue on like overfitting like
instability inside like your model and
also you know again it can be like time
consuming because again like you're
going to have a large number of the day
to do if you know like every time you
receive an update from like one person
then you will like broadcast it to like
the rest of the network and then like
the date or someone else and broadcast
again so what you going to do is that
you cannot want to aggregate everything
at once so you're like saving time so
we're way to do that some interesting
like fact and that's something that will
come back to what I said the beginning
about me being like very interesting in
like privacy so some of like the
aggregation process that we have is what
would consider likely reversible so once
you're like sending data in some way you
cannot really like inverse engineer like
what happened like what can information
like change for like the customer so in
some way it's really good because again
we're not like receiving any like
private information from the customers
just update for making model and we can
you know use different concept like
deferential privacy to be able like to
aggregate like those information in ever
in never more execute way so to example
and there is like way more than that the
one like the first one is kind of like
simple averaging so let's say you know
we have like logistic regression you
have all the parameter for like the
logistic regression and then using the
data from just from like one device you
do like the updates you see that like
the wage
for like this specific customer in some
way you like broadcast at to like the
server the server is mainly like to get
like the date for like multiple
different people and then you're going
to like the average if I call the date
like wait update that you get and the
single one is a bit more let's select
solid which is collect federated
averaging and for federated averaging
like the base of it is what collect
common initialization so common in
series Asian is on each of the device of
your customer you're going to our like
you model so it's going to be like the
same model it's going like to be you
know at some time get like the new wait
for my cue server and then like update
some of the weights that you have like
internally and but the way you're going
to select send the model at the
beginning what you want to do is to make
sure that like the initialization so
like the weight of I called you
parameter for your model at the
beginning is exactly like the same for
like on each of the different devices
and we're doing that because if we don't
what's going to about what's going to
happen is you will have like a really
big performance loss and there was like
a simple experiment that I missed so
this is the like image classification
data sets were just not some digit that
you train like to classify from pictures
and this show that the other thing like
the same initialization between I call
the different model is making it like
really hard to have unity model
converging at the end or not having like
you drop in performance and usually at
the end again doing you like the sharing
realization for everything
the final average model that we get at
the end I was like a reuse reduction in
loss compared to like the whole data
sets so I talked about like simple
averaging federally averaging but we are
like unstable compression coda situation
again like the paper that is like did
some kind of survey is like showing you
the difference in terms of like cost
speeds
some issue if you know it's your model
has some like non convexity if you need
at some additional space or in
synchronous communication and kind of
like a new paper that was really is also
like from Google
it's something to collect six or
aggregation so maybe you look for some
of you like everything that I said so
far you're saying oh we are like those
you know date of parameter and maybe you
know getting those update is already
like giving you something giving us like
some information maybe you know I could
sing that oh you know like race for like
customer is going up and down is maybe
you know going to tell us or something
is happening so if you're like an
attacker and you're getting like this
way maybe you can do something about
that and one interesting way to avoid
like the situation is what would collect
secure aggregation so secretly
aggregation who is going to do is you're
going to encrypt every time the data is
going to be sent from the device to the
server and the server will only be able
like to decrypt every like weight that
you sent only after let's say like like
a number T of people contributed to like
this computation so let's say you know
I'm sending you like information we get
like 30 people sending like this
information at some point and then once
we arrive to like this threshold and I
will show you like a bit what is like
the exchange happening between let's say
like the devices and like the server and
we'll be able like to see that only when
we were right to this threshold will be
able like to great decrypted data and
then we'll be able like to do like the
update on like the general model and
we'll be able like to send it back to
every devices so just like a quick
picture so on the left is kind of you
know what is happening today so let's
say you are you know in a cloud house
provider so Google Amazon Microsoft for
example and today what is happening is
every interaction that you have on your
mobile is going to you know generate
some intelligence and then it's going to
generate some data that is going to be
sent to like the clouds and the cloud is
going to you know maybe add a model
update they're like protein model for
example and then it's going like to send
it back to your device in the federal
federated learning like mindset what's
happening is you have this part where
the model is still like learning without
having to leave like your device in some
way so it doesn't have like to go back
to the cloud provider is already
like learning insightly directly inside
like your smartphone and then once in a
while as you can see on the right you
will have like this piece of information
this piece of knowledge that it will be
like aggregated and then that will be
you know conversate it inside like just
one piece of information which will be
like the new model will like the new
weights and that will be sent back to
every devices and in secure a gregarious
what's going to happen is you have
exactly like the same
it's a configuration except that this
aggregation that you'll have in the
middle is going to be like secure in a
way of well cryptography so like don't
worry about that usually it's a lot of
you know generating like public key
saying like the public key to someone
else being able like to decrypt it and
you have liked a lot of interaction
between the user and the server you're
waiting for you're not getting like a
enough user and like the part that are
in red I think is usually like what
guarantee is like the security of like
the whole concept so again at this point
we only like learning stuff by using
like the cleaner and inputs and we are
only able like to see that once it
arrived in the server and once like
being processed and then we never store
anything and usually like the over it is
like pretty low and we can tolerate like
a large amount of you know it filling
devices so no matter like where the
customer is like it will still work and
we'll see be able like to update the
model because when you arrive I guess
you know in a certain size like you know
like million of customer it's easy like
you just have to do like people
generating data and being able like to
give you like some information so I hope
that's you know to lust and you can do
if I can affect summarize everything
we've just this picture so if we start
by you know at the upper part in the
middle you are like all those devices
that started with a single model and
then we'll go like to a where like a
user is going to interact with me or
like maybe the application and it's
going like you change the state of like
the model that she has inside it
so it would go from you know just having
this blue circle to like a green square
and then will not get like this update
just for like one device but for every
possible devices that we have and then
everything will be aggregated and will
you know be transformed to like this
English and one season like process will
be like back in see and like this new
mobile is going to be sent I can
broadcast or like all the different
devices that we are so luckily you know
news like any like formula but we're
like in PI data so well I need to put
some code
fortunately like if you don't want to
you know go and rate thousands of paper
about like implementation details
tensorflow
released 10 so for federated and they
have like tutorial for a couple of
datasets where you can already you know
get a sense of what's happening what do
you need to use or do you write like the
code to do that so in this example you
know this is like what we are but you
will see that if you go on the website
it's way more complicated than that if
you like kind of like working progress
so you know a lot of stuff is changing
there is a lot of like improvement but
as you can see there is you know really
import we load like the simulation data
so it's some kind of like version of
like M list again like the computer
vision like image classification and
then once you have these data sets you
pick a subset of client so in this case
we just pick like three fake like
customer so we just create like a lists
it's very simple then you show like
terms of orphan already like how yours
that structure is going to be like and
then once you've done you just like
declare metamodel so in this case we're
using a cameras model and we're just
using a very simple one so it's like a
dense layer there is like ten different
classes we using like soft max because
we want to predict like just fall
classes and input set like 784 is mostly
because we dealing with
20:28 my 28 pictures then you combine
the model we use like cross-entropy we
use stochastic gradient descents we've
you know like yes I go to miser
around like 0.1 maybe like Goshen I
guess and once you're done with that
then we can just like simulates what
will happen if we're doing really like
federated average processing so we'll
just like run the model in this case
we're going active running for like five
iteration and if you look at the results
you will see that like like the loss is
decreasing no matter you know it was
going like to communicate with you and
in some ways were but again like
disclaimer it's way more complicated
than that if you go on the webpage you
know that there is like this like
releasable snipe at but like if you go
in more details there is you know like
full paragraph every time for each of
like the line that they have to really
explain details like what's happening
and if you like very interested there is
another website called leaf that's done
by karegi Mellon University and here you
have just you see like for off that I
said but there is a thing a bit more
there's like another one again from
analysts one from like sentiment
analysis another one for character
prediction and one two just like rate
sensitive data sets and what you will
see and and there is like interesting is
for each of those you select the number
of user because this is in like the way
like it should work we're not talking
about just getting like data and we
don't know like from where these data is
coming we still want to know like in a
real case what is the egg is coming from
if we can you not have like some small
batches so we cannot replicate what will
happen if you have something that's
rained production so it is like a lot of
different resources and otherwise thank
you
re-engineering us are you applying any
of this so today we are most like
looking at it because again as I said at
the beginning we are like interesting in
like being able to do like state of the
art being able like to like also like
respect like the privacy of our user I
think like the idea is maybe soon like
in a captain to be able like to
demonstrate if you know this is working
this is something that we can like
replicate with it's like real data but
so far no it's like nothing yet like
we're like very far from anything in
production
thank you for the presentation so my
question is you say there is little
overhead so did you make sure that
you'll that's a climb multi sending
black anything you say there is lot
little overhead so any measure on that
alright yeah okay so in terms of you
know it overhead again if you think
let's set on like logistic regression
let's say you have like ten parameters
and let's say use something like
cancellation what you're going to say is
you can you like just send ten times
like eight bits of information back
there's going to just say you know what
is like the value of I call each of like
those parameter so in terms of again
like overhead it's like less than
sending I know it may be like the full
world or like a sentence like to your
friend so it's again you're like really
small compared to a different middle or
like a full-blown like that I what you
need like to you know send all the data
back to like the server it's going to be
like way more expensive to do that and
you know just like send updates and
thank you for your presentations
actually I have work with this topic in
my thesis projects and the two pitfalls
that I had was one the conversions and
then the the two the efficiency because
you don't have warranties at listen my
schema I didn't have warranties of the
conversions and the efficiency origami
the efficiency and when you are
aggregating all the models and in order
to calculate the updates you are like
waiting for all the models to be trained
in order to have the update so how did
you deal with that I think here yeah
it's a real good question maybe I feel
kind of like for good tell that at the
beginning I think you know this middle
is not like the perfect solution for
everything I think you know it will be
like really useful for again maybe like
mobile that are dealing with very
sensitive information if you're doing
your like train
to predict and like forecasting by
conception like a city like please don't
use that it's like overkill but it's you
know if you are dealing with let's say
like private information maybe like
geolocation of like user that's
something that you don't want to have
you like those like gigantic data set of
like people with information of like
where they are and you like saying okay
well today you know this stuff is like
being British I'm like we're in big
trouble because this is like really not
sensitive so I think in this case is you
know I wouldn't recommend everyone to
like to switch all their model like to
use that and especially in the fact that
you know some of the limitation as you
say is like the aggregation there is you
know not everything that you can I say
expressed in terms of you like
aggregating like the weight again and
even in some of the example that they
have it's mostly in detail you know it
some texts so in my image classification
if you let's say if we think more in
terms of maybe like tabular data there
is something that is not like a spore
force you're not just like doing it by
yourself itself you're not doing it on
the side of like the devices of someone
thank you I would not
Hey hello you talk about a spectra
gladion M what is better for you Spectre
about a gradient or maximum descent or
lesson by radiant like the different
optimization that I show at some point
yeah well what prefer you I think you
know like for if you just want like to
do like a prototype I think the like
optimization like way to go is
stochastic gradient descent because like
that is just want to implement there is
you know nothing fancy to it there is
other stuff like talk wild Adam it's
just like a small list like changes to
like you're like formula that you need
like to optimize but again like I will
say like just go for x2 education
descent because it's so recent thing
that is you know quite complicated to
use if you start right from the start
doing something like very fancy just
like for the fun of it this is going to
be like really complicated for like
debugging at the end so you know there's
like try it's like the easy way and
[Music]